we have a great podcast today oh yeah i
just feel it in my bones yeah there are
days where i've felt yeah we don't have
the goods
oh but those turn out to be fantastic as
well
in fact what's your point
my point is
my point is we can do no wrong we've
been blessed by god yeah
uh what happened there
wait what was going on you're fine it
was just garbage
we were working and
this guy aaron blair just darted across
the room and made a crazy motion and
acted like no don't mind me
and we are in a special zone yeah
i was in the midst of talking about how
amazing we are we were in the pocket
play yeah what were you doing wish you
were in shot and you had to get it out
yeah what happened there i was getting
some notes we you know when we do this
podcast i we talked to the control room
the entire time you know we're chatting
already on slack and they just let me
know there was some garbage on this tool
but who cares if these guardians
i don't i'm just i don't kill the
messenger they're telling me to get rid
of the garbage i go and get rid of the
garbage
can can i just say i don't understand
what the chain of command is here i
would think that i am the captain of
this tugboat but i'm finding out that
there are people in other rooms who are
issuing commands it's a podcast who
would care if there's some
living in a simulation man can i just be
devil's advocate for a second what if
you see the video and then there's
garbage on the stool and then you're
like blai why don't you pick up the
garbage
why would i ever watch this video from
this podcast
how how bad does my life have to be
where i'm saying
honey i'm gonna go into the basement and
watch a video of my podcast so that's
number one number two is that if there's
a bottle and some papers on a stool
in that video do you think i'm going to
then uh go on a rampage
no i would not but three that's my
tissue and i've got a delicate little
runny nose
wait i just that was your
you just jumped on a on a
moist recently used tissue in the midst
of a covid i have monkey pots you know i
will say when i grabbed it i did think
oh this is kind of wet
you said this is this is kind of monkey
poxy
you got monkey pox on you i'm sorry now
he's taking it out of the trash well
don't put it back on the schools around
do you what is that even a tissue why do
i i feel like that's like a paper towel
yeah but regular tissues they just fall
apart i need something a little more
robust you know oh so so what do you use
for a tissue these these like uh hand
towels we have in the bathroom here are
fantastic for for blowing your nose
you're using the hand towels in the
bathroom to to wipe your nose like terry
cloth they're not cloth they're just you
know like heavy duty no i use those well
i don't put them back
i think you do because i went in there
the other day and there were some and i
always like to take off my shirt when i
go in the bathroom and rub whatever
tissues out all over my chest wait
that's very sensual i'm not blowing my
nose on your
body musk yes you rub them and then you
put them back i put them back carefully
yeah and then i blow my nose and put
them back yeah it's very it's a thing i
do which i was a little reluctant to
talk about because i thought it'd be
judged but i love nothing more than
finding tissues that have been used and
rubbing them over my chest it's very
sensual and mysterious
nothing i just said is true i don't want
people stopping me on the street and
saying why do you do that i do not do
that do you think people thought you
were serious i think about 18
okay yeah because i said it with great
authority and also now that i mention it
it sounds sensual and cool and i'm going
to try it
here moaning coming from the back
[Music]
don't you don't have to do it
wait that sounded more like a ghost when
someone's having an orgasm yeah that's a
haunted orgasm
nothing sexy about that i know i love a
ghost having an orchestra
don't do as i did in life
where are they coming from well it's
making them uh orgasms they're coming
from the afternoon no like coming as in
c-u-m-m-i-n oh i said it and it was a
little crass but what are what's
orgasming oh the ghost prostitute yeah
oh right okay
yeah what if ghosts just hang around and
they're because they can hang around and
just watch everything they're totally
just getting off right and they're
creeps they're we think they're there in
this scary way but it turns out they're
just loitering first of all they're
loitering they haven't been invited
they're in your personal space they see
everything and they're like oh
wait are you hunting me or you no
orgasm i'm not haunting don't stop yeah
yeah keep doing your taxes
you're doing the most mundane thing and
the ghost is it's so hot could declare
those dependents
a ghost that finds mundane things erotic
and is constantly orgasming while
orgasming well you're just around the
house trying to make some chicken noodle
soup
oh dear
tear the packet that makes the flavored
broth
boy this ghost is really getting this
that was just constantly
exhausting and because he's a ghost he's
never done if you know what i mean you
know he just goes and goes and goes well
he doesn't need to recharge no no
i'm ready to go instantly
is that what ectoplasm is yeah pretty
much oh sorry i know ghostbusters is
probably your favorite movie but i i bet
you'll never watch it the same way again
are you kidding i'll watch it but not
the same way nice
oh wow what i love ghost jizz
oh okay then that's fine
we should get started yeah we should get
started you know
it does need to end um
orgasming ghost coming soon to a theater
near you